.
>>> IN LIGHT OF TO
IFD SUCCESSFUL
REICCK VOTINGHTGISLATION,R MITC
DECLARING NOTHING THE "S
TONIGHT THERE'S SOMEONE HE MHT
E ARICOPA
COUNTY.
VISITED HIS COMPANY AND HAS THIS
. Reporter: IN THESE FINAL
T A
S IS ON THE BALLOT PAPER
ITSELF. IN FROMCH IN
RI EBATTLE CAST IN
OSCAMERAS TO ZOOM INHEAPER.
'SIS IS S D TO JEFF ELLINGTON.
HAT ARE TH LOONG FOR?
>> DON'T KNOW, WISH WE KNEW.
>> RteS IS PRESIDENT
BALLOT MARICOPA COUNTY, INGLE 2P
ARIZONA, WDUCET CK, AN AIR-TIGHU
>> THIPER. LITY WHERY BA IS BAD
>> Reporr: TS SP
ARTO SHIP.OU
THESE ROLLS.
WE DON'T HAVE PAPER MADE OUT O
BAMBOO.
>> Reporter: BAMBOT
THAT HAS BEEN CHASED. RA
>> THES COMING IN THE PAPER, T
Y FIRST RESPONSE WAS THERE'S
IT
CONTIND ELLINGTOERS US LIGHTS,
STARTEGE H MAYBE THERE IS  SO
IBLYG FOR.THEY COULD
WE COULDT  ANYTHINBALLOT THAT R
WATERMARK ORTH>> T THAT IS AN E
IN JUST ENter: STEVEN RICHER IA
RECORD DENOUNCING THIS
BY THE
SEMEAN CAN-CONTROLLED IZ
>> YOU'RE GOING TODIVISION
ANWE'RE NOT  MOVE THE
OXYGEN TO SOME OF THESE ABSURD
CONSPIRACY THEORIE, YOU KNOW, I
WHHE GAME IS HERE AND I
DON'E HOW  REALLY HELPS.
>> Reporter: OR MAKES ANY SENSE
AT ALL.
INS?
ESR MACOWED THS IN BOTH IN 2U DA
>> RorED
BETWEEN 20 A02
THERE'S  OUTRAGE IN
2020?
>> O.
>> KYUNG LOI
PHOENIX.
BE  ARE YOU LEARNINAND HOW THIR
UNVEILED?
>> Reporter:L, YOU KNOW,E SPOKES
NIGHT, ANDERSON, WE WERE HEANGT
EARLY .
THES
GAME, A LOT OF THIS UNCERTAINTY
BECAUSIZONA SENATE PRESIDENT
KAREN FAT TALKING TO A LOT
LEN OFFICIALS IN ARIZONA
LIKE THEY ANTICIPATED.
ANOTHE
E THEY UND 60 DAYSST WORD THAT T
FIND OUT WHAT IS REVEALED AN
WHAT IT COULD MEAN FOR TVOTERS
MAPAY SPECIFICALLY,
ANDERSON.
THAT, THOUCRS A LOT OF
TO HAVL THAT
TIME, THATS THIS QUESTIO
D ALTHCOEORIES AREWIRLING OUT >D
THE AM AUDITS, COLORADO'S
SECRAREADEF
PUSH IN HEE.
APPARENTLY BEEN INSPIRED BY TH
PRIVATELY-RUN AUDIT IN ARIZONA
SECRETARY GRISWOLD JOINS UW.OU.W
U TO DO IN
COLORADO.
FIRST, I WAN
THE BREAKING NEWS THA OF THE
SENATE TO MOVE FG
SER ELL SAYS IT'S NOT SSARY AND
NDERSON, THAOUATES AND THE F NE
HAVING ME ON.
MY REACTION FROM WHAT HAENIS DEN
TELOWING STATES TO SUPPRESS
THE ,  WHAT WE'RE
UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY AND THEN JUSTIFY THE
PASSING OF VOTER SUPPRESON
WESTER THE REASON THAT DEMOCRAC
IS DESTROYED BY THESE VOTER
SUPPRESSTACTAUDITSAND LITEY
INSURRECTIONISTS RUNNG
THCHS OF
ANDST ISN'T THERE AN ARGUMENT E
OTHER SIDE HERE, THAT THE LAST
E HODIDN'T LIKE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, THAT HAD FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT
SIZE-FITS-ALL POCYOR
IN EH  HAVE LD BE RUN
BEEN SOMETHING DONE UNTOWARD BY
TH PNTE
FACT THAT THE STTHR OWN VOTING
IN>> WEL WHAVOTERS NEED ON AND
CAST A BT INE
ECE'RE SEEING IS OUR
ACROSS THERENG
NATION.
AND I BEE AMERICANS ACCESS TO HA
THEIR VOICHE
ELECTRICIANS REGES TEIR SKIN, TT
MONEY IN THEIR BANK ACR ERE THEI
SO IE WITH TT
ASSESSMENT.
WE'RE AT AN URGENCY POINT
OUDEMOCRACY.
TOUN YOUECTION, AND THE OTHER W
STATES AND PARTISAN ELECTED HA
OFFICIALS STOPPED SUPPSSTHEI
ANDERSON, WIHE
SUPPRESSION BINOT ONLY
GOP MEMBERS TILTING ELECTIONS IN
THEIR FAVOR.N AS YOU CAN
GET.
RD THE LES
KYLAD  MARICOPA COUNTY.
YO SORT OF A PREEMPTIVE
ACTION IN E  EKING TO DO SOMETH
WITH YOUR
ON ANDHAT YOU DID?AT WAS GOI
>> YEAH.
ICOLOR L COUN
ELECTIONE GETTINPRESD  R THE S
AUDITS.
ATES, THEY WERE G ESSURE.
ANLIEVE THAT IN COLORADO
E  TO
PROTECOUCRACY.
THAT IS HOW I SEMYE AS
SECRETARY OFTE
SO ISSUED RULES PROBATIN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LAWE
WITH NO EXPERIENCE IS AND ON TOS
NATITH,
C.K-LIMITING AUDI
WE SHOULD MAKE I
COMPETENCE IN ELECTIONS.ERMINE
SOME OF THESE PARTISAN GOP ARE .
THAT ALTHOUGH WEEIEWORTHY
SUPPRESSE RAUDITVOTE
REPUBLICANS REALLY REFUSE TO
MOVET THE
VOTE, AMERICANOT
REPUBLICAN AMERICAN VOTERS,
THE PEOPLE ACT, SUORT THE IDEA T
LEADERS.
>> WE LDT OUN THERE WAS
CON BOTH SIDES.
HOUSES ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
TURNOUT ON B